Take a second and
scope out your competition.
What monetization methods do
they implement most often?
In your searching, have you also
found any hidden competitors?
And, by hidden, we mean companies that
might be fighting on the same budget as
you, but offering a different service.
This might require you to get a little
bit creative in your search terms.
Maybe getting very specific or
drilling down to page two or
three of the results.
But seeing what people in the same
monetary class are doing to monetize,
is a great way to get ideas for
your own product.
When researching your competitors,
take a moment and jot down the pros and
cons to their approaches
to monetization.
You can do this using
the provided boxes.